est-ce que Samsung va se faire dézinguer
est-ce que ça me saoule va souffrir
est-ce que ça me saoule va avoir mal à
cause de ce smartphone là ce smartphone
là c'est le hop là ici viens là viens à
fil point c'est le fight dance de flip
c'est ce qui vient de cette boîte là de
haut pot c'est le nouveau smartphone
super sexy c'est le nouveau smartphone
pliant pliable à clapet qui peut
vraiment venir faire mal à Samsung ici
on va donc venir regarder comparer
regarder point par point la différence
entre ces deux smartphones d'un côté le
oppo Finlande de feel de l'autre côté le
Samsung Galaxy Z flip 4 dans les deux
cas sont des smartphones avec des noms à
coucher dehors mais le truc qui est
intéressant c'est que chez oppo est bien
vous avez ce très grand écran externe
tandis que chez Samsung vous avez un
petit écran externe grand écran petit
écran ce qui accent en différence il y a
pas que ça je vous dis directement il y
a plein de différence c'est vraiment
super intéressant donc on y va
accrochez-vous prenez vous du coca
apprenez vous du pop-corn on y va c'est
parti c'est parti
[Musique]
ce sont vraiment deux produits qui
racontent quasiment la même histoire
quasiment la même histoire sauf qu'il y
a des choix qui sont quand même
relativement différents alors au-delà de
la taille de la boîte on voit qu'il y a
une vraie grosse différence au niveau de
l'épaisseur au niveau de la boîte et du
packaging parce que voilà on aime bien
faire un truc qui aide la gueule qui a
de l'envergure chez oppo parce que on
vient lancer un truc un peu cocorico
alors on n'est pas français pour autant
c'est un truc un peu en grande pompe
Samsung joue plus en la sobriété petite
boîte pas de blocs de charge vous verrez
que chez oppo vous avez un bloc de
charge qui est ici donc bon sont deux
choses très différentes et le truc qui
est intéressant et qu'on va directement
et qui est marqué là c'est le
partenariat avec un seul Blade qu'on
avait vu arriver l'année dernière chez
oppo sur le finding 5 Pro qu'on voit ici
une fois de plus sur le finden de flip
je déteste ces noms et sont vraiment à
coucher dehors mais pour autant les
produits sont très cool alors c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que j'ai vraiment la voix
qui qui parle loin aujourd'hui en fait
quand j'ai vu arriver la présentation de
ce smartphone le finden de flip je me
suis dit ça va être très très compliqué
pour Samsung pourquoi parce que
effectivement le fait d'avoir ce très
grand écran et bien ça va apporter plein
d'usages on va pouvoir s'imaginer en
train de scroller sur un Tik Tok vous
êtes sur fois que vous scrolez vous
regardez des vidéos vous êtes sur
Instagram vous scrolez alors qu'en
réalité c'est pas ça du tout cet usage
là il n'existe pas et c'est dommage
c'est vraiment vraiment dommage pour
autant je sais pas si vous avez vu ma
vidéo je vous en ai parlé je crois que
c'était au mois de décembre l'année
dernière j'avais fait une vidéo et
j'avais vu quelqu'un en train de
scroller sur Tik Tok sur cet écran
externe est-ce que c'était fake ou pas a
priori oui parce que cette
fonctionnalité n'existe pas on n'est pas
implémenté est-ce qu'elle a été dès le
départ sur certains prototypes peut-être
aller savoir en tout cas ici on l'a pas
donc on va regarder plein de choses on
va déjà regarder le côté le format on va
regarder est-ce qu'il y a un truc qui
est différent le design le concept même
on va regarder la charnière on va
regarder l'écran externe on va regarder
l'écran interne on va regarder toute la
partie photo qui est aussi extrêmement
importante d'autant plus que on se parle
de smartphone à 1000 balles presque 1000
balles voir des fois un peu plus ça
dépend et vous allez regarder ça toute
la question de la performance la
question de la batterie la question de
la charge bref il y a plein de points à
venir regarder et on va tout de suite
commencer à regarder un peu ce format
alors le format c'est quasiment le même
soyons clair les smartphones ils ont
quasiment le même format il va être un
poil plus grand au niveau du smartphone
de oppo ça joue vraiment à pas grand
chose hop là ils sont aimantés voilà ça
c'est un smartphone qui sont aimantés on
peut venir s'amuse avec leur façon la
queuleuleu si on veut parce qu'ils sont
aimantés mais sinon c'est vraiment
quasiment la même chose on va avoir un
côté un peu vague là qui est joli qui
est bien dessiné du côté de chez oppo
ici je sais pas si vous le voyez bien
chez Samsung c'est aussi premium c'est
très joli c'est bien fait voilà dans les
deux cas ça fonctionne bien une
certification IPX4 chez oppo
identification IPX8 chez Samsung bon
voilà ok ça change pas bien grand-chose
différence également au niveau de la
charnière parce que chez oppo vous avez
une charnière en goutte d'eau charnière
en goutte d'eau elle fait quoi elle fait
que ça vient totalement se fermer que
c'est fermé c'est poser c'est poser la
différence c'est que vous avez une
charnière en U chez Samsung qui va faire
un petit u alors je vais essayer de vous
le montrer pour vous puissiez le voir un
peu comme ça si je prends une charnière
en goutte d'eau et que je mets un petit
truc derrière et bien voyez je ne vois
rien à travers ça ne passe pas c'est
fermé c'est bien fermé parce que si je
prends une charnière en U et bien je
vois à travers très clairement donc me
direz-vous quel va être la grosse
différence charnière au goutte d'eau
versus charnière en U en fait la
différence elle va se sentir ce que vous
ouvrez votre smartphone et que vous le
posez et ça sent réellement parce que le
finden de flip c'est l'héritier du
finden que je vous avais déjà pas la
présenter qui est pas un produit qui est
sorti en France mais qui vraiment
l'héritier et la grosse différence vous
sentez sous le doigt alors croyez-moi
sur parole parce que vous pourrez pas
vous faire le test on semble davantage
la charnière sur le smartphone de
Samsung et on la sent beaucoup moins sur
le smartphone de oppo mais c'est de
l'ordre d'une sensation qui est divisé
par deux c'est vraiment ça là alors on
la sent attention on la sent on va pas
dire qu'on la sent pas on la sent
réellement mais on la sent beaucoup
moins sous le doigt on sent plus de
profondeur et c'est beaucoup plus net
chez Samsung ça allait beaucoup moins
cher au pot après elle se dérangeant
chez Samsung j'ai envie de vous dire non
parce qu'on s'y habitue que dans tous
les cas ça fonctionne bien mais ça peut
la différence que vous allez avoir au
niveau de cette charnière le repos
m'affirme que cette charnière elle a été
certifiée par toysrenland pour pouvoir
être ouverte et fermé pendant 400000
fois bon on peut y aller franchement je
crois pas sur parole là-dessus il y a
pas de souci de toute façon s'il y a des
problèmes il y a des garanties derrière
donc bon ça va le faire voilà au niveau
de cette différence au niveau de la
charnière il y a aussi une autre
différence alors ça c'est peut-être plus
anecdotique mais ça peut aussi être
important c'est-à-dire les couleurs
c'est oppo vous avez deux couleurs vous
l'avez soit en noir soit en mauve pas
plus pas moins chez Samsung il y a plus
de choix lavande graphite or bleu voilà
donc vous avez le choix ici c'est la
couleur lavande chez Samsung vous avez
également comme chez oppo mais tout un
écosystème on peut venir assortir la
couleur de sawash avec ses écouteurs
avec son smartphone bref on peut venir
faire plein plein de trucs on est
également sur un produit qui est très
élégant très sophistiqué et très joli du
côté de chez oppo bon voilà ça c'est
vraiment une question de goût ça change
globalement pas grand chose Corning
Gorilla Glass 5 ici il y a chez oppo
korniglas victus chez Samsung la
différence c'est que vous avez deux
génération pour ceux qui sont pas
Corning c'est une marque qui fait des
gorillas et ses gorillas sont des vers
des vers résistants et il y a eu
plusieurs générations le 5 qu'on a ici
après il y a eu le 6 et le 7 c'est le
victus il a changé non c'est plus le 7
c'est le victus mais les victus vous
l'avez ici donc en fait vous aurez un
verre qui sera de plus ancienne
génération sur smartphone de oppo et de
dernière génération sur le smartphone de
Samsung voilà pour expliquer l'histoire
et dans les deux cas le sur les
smartphones qui font quasiment le même
poids 187 grammes versus 191 grammes
autant dire que c'est kiffe qui vous
Rico mon lapin maintenant le truc qui me
fait vraiment la différence c'est pas
l'écran interne qui a quasiment la même
taille on va regarder dans quelques
instants c'est vraiment cet écran
externe qui est super important à me
regarder alors attends il se regarde
plutôt comme ça il y a une vraie
avec mon capteur d'empreinte digitale
pour la sécurité je vais avoir un truc
qui a plutôt bien fait toute la partie
photo portrait que je trouve vraiment
bien bien réussi chez Samsung c'est un
peu moins sexy c'est à dire que je
retrouve
petit aperçu mais j'ai pas mes boutons
là
donc un peu un peu moins ouf après
j'appuie sur photo je viens choisir et
là j'arrive sur mon appareil photo et là
par contre d'un point de vue purement
logiciel alors tenez votre téléphone à
l'endroit pour le meilleur résultat ils
le veulent dans l'autre sens ok on peut
le mettre dans l'autre sens si tu veux
mon lapin et c'est tout de suite
beaucoup plus clair et ça c'est
vachement cool c'est-à-dire que je me
vois beaucoup mieux c'est beaucoup plus
grand photo portrait vidéo c'est clair
c'est lisible ça me va bien alors je
peux faire comme chez Samsung
c'est-à-dire mettre la main devant il va
reconnaître et il déclenche la photo on
y va voilà donc là vous voyez sur la
verticale la sauce regarde ma photo je
suis sur ce format là et lorsque je
l'ouvre également je suis sur ce format
là donc ça fonctionne je comprends très
bien où j'en suis et ça c'est malin et
intelligent donc là dessus il y a
absolument aucun problème donc ça c'est
vraiment un truc que je vais venir aimer
ici et que je retrouve pas
nécessairement chez Samsung une fois de
plus je peux venir enregistrer de la
vidéo et ça je le fais avec la meilleure
caméra puisque les meilleurs caméras
sont à l'extérieur et je vous donne la
comparatif de ce bloc photo par rapport
à ce bloc photo vous allez voir c'est
quand même une différence qui est assez
significative donc ça c'est pour la
partie photo ensuite il y a également le
mode portrait le mode vidéo en fait sur
uniquement des raccourcis de navigation
par rapport à ce que j'ai là il y a pas
de très très grosse différence et après
je redescends comme d'hab alors voyez
quand même une différence donc là
effectivement je peux venir changer
changer de mode chez Samsung photo vidéo
mais j'y vois rien c'est tout petit
portrait alors j'ai la même chose mais
je me rends pas compte photo qui est
donc là je mets la main mais je me rends
pas compte de mon cadre et c'est ça en
fait qui est un peu plus relou c'est
qu'en fait vraiment ici je vois pas mon
cadre bon pour autant elle est pas
loupée je l'ai elle est dedans mais
voyez on se rend beaucoup moins compte
donc il y a un côté beaucoup plus
pratique pour venir faire des photos et
des vidéos avec votre grand écran de
oppo ici ça c'est plutôt bien mais dans
un cas comme dans l'autre ce sont des
écrans de notification même si on peut
dire contrôler deux
trois pouvoirs l'utiliser
pour donner plus de possibilités chez
Samsung que chez oppo donc votre écran
d'accueil veut dire personnalisé
différentes manières la musique que vous
écoutez ici un petit Spotify si on veut
pourquoi pas la météo ça c'est des
notifications par rapport à mon agenda
une alarme si j'ai une alarme calcul du
nombre de pas un enregistreur un
minuteur mon agenda des scènes que je
peux me dire mettre avec Smart things
pour le piloter ma maison connectée par
exemple je peux mettre mes contacts
trois contacts j'appuie sur un contact
ça appelle alors pour appeler soit j'ai
des écouteurs soit j'ouvre et puis voilà
alors aujourd'hui chez oppo je vais me
retrouver avec un peu moins de
possibilités je vais avoir la partie
photo je vais avoir la météo je vais
avoir mon agenda mon minuteur mon
enregistreur et mon écouteur sans fil
piloter mes écouteurs sans fil si j'ai
des oppos en cause je peux venir les
avoir ici alors va arriver très bientôt
la dictée vocale qu'on pourra venir
faire directement ici et puis Spotify et
puis j'imagine que d'autres modes qui
vont arriver dans les temps à venir et
probablement aussi du côté de chez
Samsung après vous descendez vous avez
votre centre de contrôle ici qui est
quand même plutôt bien fait vos
notifications sur le bas et puis c'est
tout voyez et si on veut regarder
l'équivalent ici chez Samsung j'ai mes
contrôles ici avec des grosses icônes et
puis sur le bas j'ai pas de notification
je les ai l'autre côté en allant un peu
plus loin donc en fait c'est juste un
écran un peu plus grand mais qui va
parler pas de faire beaucoup de choses
d'autres
ça parce que vous essayez de
l'écran autre chose là
-dessus comme mettre un petit chat voilà
donc ça c'est un peu dommage avoir
comment on peut faire évoluer sa
solution dans les temps à venir tandis
que à l'intérieur et vous l'avez aperçu
vous avez aussi un très grand écran
alors là c'est même combat même histoire
chez Samsung c'est du
6e peau c'est du 6,8 pouces ok
légèrement plus épais chez oppo que chez
Samsung ça joue vraiment globalement à
pas grand chose c'est le même principe
avec la caméra qui est positionné au
milieu dans les deux cas on va jusqu'à
120 Hertz full HD+ d'un côté de l'autre
bon c'est sensiblement la même chose je
trouvais juste le finden de flip de oppo
un poil plus lumineux que le Galaxy Z
flip 4 après en terme de tenue de
charnière bah ça se tient hein regardez
je peux me prendre sur l'un comme sur
l'autre la charnière se tient bien d'un
côté et de l'autre laver je le blocs pas
regardez je peux aller jusque là avec au
pot avec Samsung là il fait un bruit
quand j'arrive vraiment au bout et là ça
me saoule il vient presque même là vous
voyez il tient tout seul là il tient
tout seul la charnière tu es toute seule
là il tient encore ah là il est fermé
une fois de plus ça c'est vraiment du
pôle détail je pense pas que il ferme un
peu plus vite chez une peau c'est les
différentes choix les technologies de
charnière qui sont employés très
clairement on s'en fout de l'avoir
ouvert comme ça donc c'est pas important
ce qu'on va avoir c'est ce fameux Flex
mode c'est là où il faut que ça tienne
parce que si le flex mode ne tient pas
et bien rien ne tient et là c'est
relativement un petit peu dommage donc
là hop là je suis en Flex mode je peux
l'ouvrir davantage je me dis que si je
le fais attention à ce que je le pose
comme ça ça ne va pas bouger normalement
ça bouge pas un loyer si je le mets
comme ça faut vraiment pas que ça bouge
je peux mettre un peu comme ça ça tient
très bien j'ai aucun problème du côté de
chez oppo mais c'est vrai que je peux le
régler plus facilement et plus finement
sur le smartphone de Samsung que sur le
smartphone de oppo voyez je le mets
comme ça il s'arrête n'importe où en
fait hein il s'arrête vraiment même
juste là il s'arrête n'importe où je le
poste c'est fin ça bouge pas j'ai
l'impression que des fois ça bouge
légèrement plus vous voyez il y a moi
cette sensation un peu de solidité c'est
pas vrai mais de position je le mets il
bouge pas j'ai l'impression que des fois
il bouge un poil il y a un côté voyez là
je le monte il redescent très légèrement
je préférais la charnière de Samsung ici
que je vais trouver je la pose elle est
comme ça elle va pas bouger légèrement
elle va pas descendre légèrement non
chez oppo c'est un peu différent donc
ici je préfère quand même la charnière
de Samsung même si une fois de plus
c'est une charnière en U qui permet de
voir à travers par rapport à la
charnière en goutte d'eau où on voit
strictement rien à travers et qu'une
fois de plus on sentira moins le cliché
au pot que j'ai Samsung voyez il faut
savoir un peu ce qu'on veut alors il y a
une autre différence que j'ai vraiment
noté et qui est intéressante c'est la
différence au niveau de l'audio dans les
deux cas là des haut-parleurs stéréo
dans les deux cas là du Dolby Atmos dans
les deux cas ça fonctionne bien soyons
clair mais par contre le truc qui est
intéressant c'est que le son sera plus
fort il y aura plus de puissance sonore
Samsung touchez au pot avec un spec qui
sera un peu plus large on aura un peu
plus de rondeurs et un peu plus de
précision alors on se parle de
haut-parleur téléphone on n'est pas sur
un truc non plus ou on se fait waouh
waouh c'est complètement œil mais c'est
quand même mieux c'est beaucoup mieux
fait c'est du point de détails après ce
que je vous conseille c'est de prendre
des écouteurs des bugs pourquoi pas des
buzz de chaque marque pour moi être
tranquille et être sûr d'une sorte d'une
compatibilité maximale tout en sachant
que chez Samsung vous avez du Bluetooth
5.2 je suis oppose du Bluetooth 5.3 bon
voilà c'est globalement pas grand chose
maintenant il y a un autre truc qui est
super super intéressant c'est la
question la performance oui et vous
allez voir pourquoi parce qu'en fait
chez Samsung vous avez un stade dragon
vous êtes chez Qualcomm c'est un dragon
8 gène 1 qui est le processeur qui est
sorti l'année dernière de quoi alcool
qui chauffait un peu mais qui fonctionne
quand même plutôt pas mal là vous avez
un dimensity 9000 plus qui est une puce
de médiathèque qui très haut de gamme
chez médiathèque qui fonctionne bien
également mais il y a une petite
différence alors je vous donne des
données chiffrées parce que c'est le
benchmark qui me ressort ça c'est à dire
que je vais aller un peu moins loin du
côté de chez médiathèque par rapport au
processeur de Qualcomm c'est quoi le com
et je fais un million
9997 tandis que chez oppo j'arrive à 891
818 je vais aller un peu moins loin en
termes de performance avec mon
smartphone de peau qu'avec mon
smartphone de Samsung après je suis pas
convaincu que dans l'effet dans les
usages vous sentir réellement une grosse
différence ici vous regardez la
différence au niveau du CPU je vais
aller quand même plus loin un peu plus
de 50000 de plus au niveau du CPU sur
mon smartphone de Samsung au niveau du
GPU donc graphique c'est sensiblement la
même chose ça se tient à peu près dans
un mouchoir de poche il y a 10 % des cas
niveau de la mémoire c'est exactement la
même chose au niveau de l'X exactement
la même chose donc il y a une petite
différence au niveau CPU très légère au
niveau du GPU mais je vous le dis une
fois de plus si vous n'êtes pas un
hardcore gamer sur smartphone je mets
guillemets quand je dis ça bon vous
sentirez vraiment pas la différence donc
vous voyez pour moi il y a pas de grosse
différence là-dessus très très
clairement et voyez ça c'est typiquement
le charnière je la prends chez le pot je
peux pas le faire tenir comme je
voudrais alors que chez Samsung ça va
tout de suite lire beaucoup mieux il y a
un truc qui aspire quand même plus la
solidité chez Samsung que chez oppo
c'est du point de détail après dans les
deux cas vous aurez un processeur
extrêmement performant qui va très bien
dans les deux cas vous avez 8 Go de RAM
et chez Samsung vous avez deux configs
soit une config avec un stockage en 128
soit une config avec un stockage en 256
alors que chez oppo c'est que 256 donc
bon faut dire faire votre choix
également je voudrais les tarifs dans
quelques instants et il y a une
différence qu'on a ici chez oppo qu'on a
pas chez Samsung c'est la puce Marie si
l'icône X qui est là pour le traitement
de la photo qu'on retrouve sur ce
smartphone et qui avait vraiment
cartonné l'année dernière au niveau du
Fine Dick 5 Pro qui était mon smartphone
coup de cœur de l'année 2022 qui était
mon smartphone préféré de l'année 2022
on retrouve cette même puce ici dans le
finden finden oh là là j'arrive plus
finden de flip parce qu'il est
constructeurs pour nous donner des noms
aussi simple vous savez quand un
constructeur va construire un smartphone
et bien le moment il commence à bosser
dessus jusqu'à ce qu'il soit officialisé
il donne un nom de code ça peut être
j'en sais rien moi dragon bisou voilà
c'est un dragon bisou pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils appelleraient pas le smartphone
Samsung dragon bisou au lieu de
l'appeler le Galaxy Z flip 4 c'est c'est
alors on comprend les gars et tout
bordel ok reprenons on va regarder la
batterie rien un sujet qui est aussi
super intéressant et si vous avez une
plus petite batterie du côté de chez
l'impression que de côté de chez oppo
3700 milliampères heure 4300 millions
par heure on a 600 milliards de
différence alors on dirait vous est-ce
que c'est vraiment significatif oui et
non ce qui est vraiment significatif
surtout c'est que effectivement sur le
papier on va un peu moins loin ici que
ici mais surtout la vraie grosse
différence c'est que là vous avez une
petite boîte donc vous avez pas de bloc
de charge inclus tandis que là vous avez
une énorme boîte et vous avez un bloc de
charge inclus en plus ce qui est
intéressant c'est que chez Samsung vous
recharger au maximum jusqu'en 25 watts
alors que chez oppo vous montez en 44
watts et c'est là où au pot et c'est
marrant jusqu'à 44 watts oui sauf que si
vous regardez hop là sur notre bac de
charge on vous livre un bloc de charge
de 67 watts donc 67 watts mais vous
allez charger jusqu'en 44 watts maximum
bon donc ça va quand même aller plus
vite c'est de la super vous très bonne
technologie il faut savoir que au niveau
de ses smartphones vous avez en fait des
batteries qui sont partagées en deux
parce que ils vont mettre pas la
batterie dans un seul et même endroit
pour des questions de finesse et donc à
bout de batterie si un bout de batterie
ici c'est exactement la même chose ici
mais bon voilà la batterie de Samsung
est un peu moins grande que la batterie
de oppo alors autre sujet et là ça
devient extrêmement passionnant c'est
toute la partie photo regardez en fait
vous le voyez c'est beaucoup plus gros
ici que ici c'est juste histoire de un
peu plus beau en fait la réalité c'est
que vous avez une confit qui est
vraiment intéressante chez oppo qui a un
peu plus loin du côté de chez Samsung en
tout cas sur le papier et je vais vous
montrer les photos dans quelques
instants donc restez bien avec moi en
fait sur cet appareil là vous avez deux
optiques vous avez un grand angle et un
ultra grand-angle on se parle de
smartphone aux alentours de 1000 € ici
il y a pas de téléobjectif donc c'est
pas nouveau c'est comme ça peut-être
qu'il y a-t-il pas la place pour
l'inclure moi pour faire des choix au
niveau fabrication et ce qui est évident
c'est que le consommateur ira davantage
vers un smartphone où on va avoir un
grand angle et un ultra grand temps qui
correspondent à la majeure partie des
usages versus un téléobjectif qu'on
utilisera un petit peu moins c'est la
raison pour laquelle ils ont fait soit
là donc chez oppo vous avez 50
mégapixels plus un 8 mégapixels sur
l'ultra grand-angle donc le capteur
principal c'est un 50 mégapixels c'est
pas négligeable c'est intéressant tandis
que c'est Samsung vous êtes sur 12 + 12
grands angles et ultra grand-angle pour
les ouvertures sur les mêmes on va
parler bien plus loin dessus dans tous
les cas vous avez un zoom numérique x 10
et vous avez chez oppo une caméra de
selfie qui est planqué juste en haut ici
le 32 mégapixels c'est la même que sur
le fight X5 pro tandis que chez Samsung
il y a les planquer là c'est mégapixels
c'est un peu petit quand même mais bon
ok on va pas s'arrêter là on va regarder
une fois de plus mais là où il y a un
truc qui est quand même relativement
déconnant chez oppo et je suis désolé
vous avez déconné et c'est pas normal à
ce tarif là c'est que là où chez Samsung
vous prenez votre smartphone on va se
mettre une shower cap d'un hôtel ici et
bien sur ce smartphone j'ai une
stabilisation optique c'est-à-dire que
je peux venir zoomer je me mets en X 4
c'est stabilisé moi j'ai un tremblement
essentiel je suis un très bon crash test
pour ça c'est stabilisé bon tant bien
que mal je tremble quand même de la main
mais c'est stabilisé pour venir fouter
c'est pratique alors que chez oppo un
tarif à 1000 balles au niveau d'un
smartphone vous n'avez aucune
stabilisation optique et si je me mets
en X 5 regardez le résultat ça bouge ça
bouge vraiment regardez ce qui est
déconnant avec le finden de flip c'est
que vous avez aucune stabilisation
optique là je tiens demain alors moi
j'ai un tremblement essentiel regardez
lorsque je viens zoomer alors attendez
là je suis sur voisin je change
d'optique je passe sur l'ultra grand
temps que j'ai aucune stabilisation ni
optique ni électronique et lorsque je
passe sur le foie de gérien mais alors
moi il te tremblement essentiel est-ce
que ça donne x 5 et en X 10 et là on se
parle d'un téléphone n'a plus de 1000 €
quand même tandis que sur le Galaxy Z
flip 4 regardez en X 1 c'est hyper
stabilisé x 0,5 bon c'est pas la même
histoire c'est moi stabiliser mais Aline
c'est moins dérangeant et lorsque je
passe en X 2 en X 4 en X 10 bah ça bouge
pas ça c'est hyper stabilisé et ça c'est
quand même vachement bien regardez les
résultats des photos on a sur
la panne Samsung Galaxy Z4 à droite on
est sur le oppo finden de flip alors on
va tout de suite reconnaître la
signature Samsung je vous le dis c'est
beaucoup plus saturé on va avoir de
l'herbe plus verte par rapport à ce
qu'on a ici avec un côté plus naturel
chez oppo que chez Samsung à contrario
je vais avoir un ciel un peu plus bleu
ici chez Samsung et essayer un peu plus
gris et au pot donc la capteur 12
mégapixels versus capteur 50 mégapixels
vous allez voir c'est le nom de
stabilisation optique il y a vraiment
changé grand chose ou pas on passe sur
ultra grand-angle on a toujours la même
question de la saturation c'est beaucoup
plus vert en fait ici on le voit même
dans le ciel alors qu'ici c'est pas tout
à fait la même chose voyez d'un côté de
l'autre bon ultra grand temps que je
passe très rapidement on vient se
rapprocher un peu ici avec un X 2 qui me
paraît pas mal ici et aussi intéressant
du côté de chez oppo c'est beaucoup plus
regardez la saturation et une vraie
grosse différence de saturation ici même
au niveau des fleurs en bas on vient se
rapprocher ensuite en x 4 x 5 à peu près
et ensuite on vient se rapprocher
jusqu'en x 10 et soyons clairs donc
voilà on se rapproche soyons clairs le X
10 ne servira globalement à pas grand
chose alors regardons ce qui a regardé
effectivement si vous aimez les photos
un peu plus saturé un peu plus flatteuse
il faut aller chez Samsung le verre sera
plus vert plus pétant ça ira un peu plus
loin par contre il y a un truc qui est
intéressant chez oppo et on le verra
notamment sur d'autres photos si je
trouve qu'il y a plus de détails en
réalité capteur 50 pixel qui fait le taf
et qui est là pour ça il y a un peu plus
de détails je trouve au niveau des
photos alors ça va dépendre des images
mais alors ce qui achète Samsung est
bien il fonctionne très bien il y a pas
de souci là-dessus mais il y a un petit
truc en plus si on pouvait ça me
surprend parce qu'en fait vu que on a
pas cette stabilisation je dis ça va
être horrible j'appuie ça va bouger et
ben non il y a quand même une bonne
capacité de calcul et ça c'est quand
même plutôt pas mal fichu regardez on va
venir se rapprocher ici on va venir
zoomer légèrement et bien je vais
trouver la photo de Samsung un peu moins
bonne et je trouve que l'algo vient
travailler différemment pour essayer de
de lisser un peu le trait alors que chez
oppo comme on part dans 50 mégapixels et
qu'on vient zoomer dans l'image et bien
c'est pas mal franchement c'est pas mal
si vous regardez les petites branches
devant la fenêtre il y a une vraie
différence entre ce qu'on a chez Samsung
ici et ce qu'on vient retrouver chez
oppola pour moi la qualité de l'image
sera meilleur ici chez oppo que chez
Samsung faut-il encore à ce moment-là il
a les photos qui sont à poil plus terne
un peu moins saturé et là si je vais
zoomer davantage vous le verrez aussi
vous voyez il y a un côté un peu plus
naturel un peu plus clair un peu plus
normale jolie chez oppo versus qu'on a
chez Samsung sur ce smartphone live dans
cette config là vous voyez bon lorsque
je vais être il y a un moment de plus
rien ne marche soyons clairs alors là
j'aime bien ce que je vois bien le
détail de l'arbre je trouve bien il est
pas mal mais le traitement est quand
même un peu différent soyons clairs de
l'un et l'autre là sur cette photo j'ai
préféré Samsung j'ai trouvé un peu plus
flatteur ultra grand-angle là je l'aime
pas je le trouve pas très beau là vous
voyez une vraie différence de
colorimétrie c'est pas ouf d'un côté de
l'autre là je préfère quand je la zoomer
en fait c'est là où je préfère le boulot
de de oppo au niveau de l'herbe là voyez
je trouve ça moins précis ici côté algo
qui marche moins bien parce qu'en fait
forcément comme si vous voulez je pars
sur un capteur 12 mégapixels et je viens
pas zoomer dans mon image il y a pas
rogner dans mon capteur en fait j'ai un
12 mégapixels je peux sortir une photo
en 6 mégapixels alors que quand je parle
dans 50 mégapixels et bien je peux venir
à l'intérieur et me sortir un équivalent
24 mégapixels en gros si on veut ça peut
l'idée ou à 25 mégapixels donc je peux
même descendre jusqu'à 12 mégapixels
donc je peux me dire vraiment zoomer
dans mon image et sans perdre de qualité
et c'est là où en venant zoomer qu'un x
2 et bien que oppo sera meilleur que
Samsung et même sur une photo de base
elles sont quand même un peu plus de
détails voilà donc bon après très
clairement sur des smartphones comme ça
si vous avez pas de téléobjectif ne vous
amusez pas à venir zoomer vous risquez
franchement des surpris vous voyez le
détail là c'est beaucoup plus joli
afficher au pot que chez Samsung ou
c'est beaucoup plus brouillon et c'est
beaucoup moins joli sans parler de venir
trop zoomer ou un moment c'est
complètement dégueulasse alors les
caméras de selfie je suis convaincu ni
par l'un ni par l'autre c'est beaucoup
de termes je trouve ici chez Samsung
alors si vous mettez vraiment le Story
en face de vous c'est un peu mieux mais
sinon je trouve terre et même à
contre-jour c'est pas ouf je suis au pot
il y a une couleur qui est un petit peu
trop sur le rose je trouve pas très joli
regardez la teinte de peau là c'est pas
naturel c'est beaucoup trop rose on le
voit aussi dans le ciel il est un petit
peu trop rose donc je suis pas très très
fan d'ici de ce qu'ils font même à
contre-jour c'est pas dingue ça marche
pas très très bien là c'est un peu moins
pire mais là c'est pareil c'est rose
regardez il y a un peu de rose de
partout donc moi je trouve pas terrible
leur traitement ici je vous ai encore
fait quelques autres images pour venir
vous montrer mais une fois de plus j'ai
préféré le rendu ici de oppo versus le
rendu de Samsung vous voyez sur un X 2
c'est flagrant c'est beaucoup plus joli
le détail qu'on va voir ici que le
détail qu'on va voir là même ici la
voyez juste en dessous là c'est beaucoup
plus naturel chez vous pour que chez
Samsung soyons clair et puis à des
derniers points à venir considérer c'est
la partie de l'expérience logiciel alors
regardez je vous le montre ici chez
Samsung on retrouve one ui 5.1 la
dernière mise à jour et là fonctionne
bien j'aime beaucoup d'ailleurs je vous
ai fait une vidéo avec plein d'astuces
allez sur ma chaîne youtube j'aime
beaucoup Emmanuel 5.1 qui marche très
bien superbe expérience ici de Samsung
avec plein de choses qu'on peut venir
faire c'est clair c'est lisible bref
très cool très bonne expérience ça ça me
battrait très bien mais j'aime bien
aussi colorés et c'est vraiment des
expériences que je préfère également sur
Android c'est clair c'est bien séparer
là vous avez vraiment différentes
parties avec différentes séparations
comme un peu sur One uy je trouve ça
assez bien ils ont fait le choix de la
même manière de venir mettre des icônes
de couleurs il y a plein de petites
fonctionnalités notamment au niveau de
votre écran externe vous avez la
fonctionnalité d'écran pliable regardez
qui est juste ici vous allez pouvoir
retrouver au widget votre style d'écran
de couverture avec plein de styles
différents qui sont assez sympa alors
moi je vous ai mis le chat mais vous
avez différents animaux interactifs qui
vont dire interagir avec vous en
fonction de ce que vous allez venir
faire il y a les widgets ici qu'on
pourra venir activer désactiver là je
les ai tous mis mais vous vous êtes pas
obligé de tous les mettre ça dépend une
fois de plus de vous alors une fois de
plus on a plus chez Samsung qui en a ici
vous avez la question réponse rapide
vous pouvez mettre quelques petites
réponses rapides qu'on va venir piloter
directement ok why not chez Samsung
c'est aussi très clair vous avez un
petit onglet écran externe ici sur
lequel vous allez retrouver le style
d'horloge un peu de la même manière
alors c'est fatalement mais vous avez
plein de possibilités ça c'est très très
cool vous allez hop là annuler vous
allez retrouver également vos petits
widgets que vous allez venir activer
désactiver bon ok je vous les ai montrés
why notez réorganiser également ici
afficher vos notifications bref il y a
pas mal de possibilités donc c'est vrai
que pour moi ce sont deux expériences
logiciels qui sont assez proches très
complexes l'une et l'autre elle se base
toutes les deux sur Android 13 one uy
5.1 basé sur Android 13 colorés 13 basé
sur Android 13 ça fonctionne bien donc
c'est très cool de ce côté là alors
après il y a la différence il y a la
différence du prix regardez je vous le
dis il est là je voulais noter du côté
de chez oppo vous avez une seule config
c'est la configuration 8 Go de RAM avec
512 il y a de stockage on est ici à 1099
€, on est un peu au-dessus des 1000
euros c'est Samsung vous avez deux
possibilités soit 828 à 999 euros ça
joue globalement pas grand chose moi il
y a 100 balles d'écart avec lui donc je
vous conseille de venir doubler le
stockage passer à 256 et vous êtes à
1059 euros vous restez moins cher donc
en fait si vous prenez le Samsung Galaxy
Z flip vous êtes 40 euros moins cher que
le oppo finden de flip mais vous avez le
même stockage et la même technologie de
RAM alors il y a aussi une autre
différence à venir connaître c'est que
chez Samsung vous pourrez mettre une
seule carte SIM une seule carte SIM en
5G plus une sim si besoin tandis que je
suis au propre et mettre deux cartes SIM
de carte SIM 5G plus une ici mon plus
dans les deux cas vous avez du NFC
notamment pour le paiement des
matérialisé vous avez du wifi 6 d'un
côté mais également de l'autre bref de
ce smartphone qui sont très complets
alors mon retour personnel il y a
plusieurs choses déjà on va parler juste
de marcher il est évident que Samsung
vendra toujours plus de Galaxy Z flip 4
que oppo ne vendra de finden de Flip en
tout cas aujourd'hui on se met du modèle
find N2 flip je dis pas à l'avenir ce
qui va se passer pourquoi parce que
Samsung est le leader du marché la
marque Samsung rassure énormément et il
est évident que les consommateurs auront
plus facilement chez Samsung que chez
oppo je trouve par contre que pour un
écran de notification puisque ça reste
un écran de notification et de léger
contrôle je trouve que c'est mieux
réussi du côté de chez oppo que de chez
Samsung autre truc que j'ai préféré du
côté de chez oppo plutôt que chez
Samsung c'est effectivement leur pliure
qu'on sent beaucoup moins souvent mais
vraiment beaucoup moins c'est l'heure
d'être divisé par deux donc comme ça ok
c'est chouette maintenant j'aime moins
la charnière de oppo par rapport à celle
de Samsung je la trouve un peu moins pas
moins solide mais elle est moins elle
est pas crantée mais elle va moins
s'arrêter je dis tu te mets là elle
s'arrête là alors allez le fait aussi
mais vous voyez là je remonte elle
redescend un peu il y a un truc qui est
un peu moins net ici du côté de chez
oppo que ce qu'on a du côté de chez
Samsung alors pour autant au pot
regardez je la prends je la pose elle
s'arrête je ne t'ai rien demandé donc il
y a un sujet là-dessus qui est super
important parce que quand on veut un
smartphone qui se plie on veut pouvoir
être assuré alors tu as un vrai une
langue me dit 400000 pliages fermeture
sans aucun problème ici chez oppo je les
crois moi je veux pas m'habiller toute
la journée mais je trouve qu'on
apprenant il y a une sensation de
Premium qui est un peu moindre que ce
que j'ai du côté de chez Samsung alors
après le fait d'avoir un audio qui est
un peu meilleur chez Samsung que chez
oppo globalement on s'en fout parce
qu'on va pas me dire écoutez comme ça et
on va pas réellement s'en rendre compte
on va voir les deux bon c'est du point
de détail la performance elle a tous les
côtés le plus grosse batterie ici un peu
moins bon voilà c'est vrai que je trouve
que le smartphone de peau a plus de plus
qu'on a le smartphone de Samsung il est
plus sexy clairement mais il y a des
trucs où on se dit ah cette charnière
c'est con quoi pourtant elle est bien
ils nous ont dit par rapport au finden
de l'année il y a deux ans me
semble-t-il la charnière a été améliorée
je lui crois hein mais bon je pense
qu'il y a encore un peu taf à faire
est-ce que c'est la Charrière en goutte
d'eau qu'il faut revenir voir j'en sais
rien moi je le trouve bien ce smartphone
je trouve très joli mais je suis
convaincu et je reste convaincu que
Samsung avant toujours plus je sais que
c'est Samsung c'est un carton plein se
forma est un carton plein qui fonctionne
vraiment aussi bien sur une si masculine
que sur une cible féminine moi c'est le
format de pliable que je préfère
aujourd'hui maintenant vers lequel je
peux vous recommander d'aller c'est
compliqué les deux sont très bien je
dirais que cet écran me plaît beaucoup
plus à cette charnière me plaît plus
vous voyez donc bon il y a du plus il y
a du moins j'ai du mal à trancher c'est
vrai que en le regardant comme ça et
même en l'ayant montré à ma femme elle
me dit waouh c'est ça qu'il faut c'est
bien il est beau cet écran c'est clair
il est extrêmement séduisant donc en
fait la vraie question à se dire c'est
Samsung qu'est-ce que vous attendez pour
venir mettre un écran plus grand et me
mettre sur le Galaxy Z flip 5 un vrai
grand écran qui pour le coup serait un
concurrent sérieux du finden de flip il
est évident que je trouve que le
smartphone de oppo est plus sexy que le
smartphone de Samsung mais pour autant
c'est Samsung qui continuer a de vendre
davantage c'est peut-être à mon sens
mais c'est comme ça d'ailleurs dites-moi
vous ce que vous en pensez en bas dans
les commentaires et puis bien évidemment
continuera parler de smartphone de
smartphone qui plie et de oppo parce que
j'espère pour arriver leur nouveau
smartphone en quelques temps le oppo
finden 5 Pro le oppo finden 6 pro je
croise les doigts pour l'instant j'ai
absolument aucune info on verra on en
parle bientôt je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]